thank you very much yes we as you know
we are hosting the asia-europe meeting
as I'm here in Brussels this week
and in light of this I'm very happy that
the Commission just a couple of hours
ago adopted the EU Vietnam trade and
investment agreements so both of these
agreements showing our strong commitment
to our partnership with Vietnam these
agreements are important for many
reasons of course they will help as our
trade policy does to increase trade and
investment growth jobs boosting trade
with one of Asia's most dynamic
economies European companies will get
preferential access to the growing and
quickly developing markets obvious now
with more than 92 million consumers and
Vietnam exporters will get easier access
to Europe for their products this will
help also to spread our standards and
create better possibilities for
effecting change when it comes to human
rights and the protection of citizens
the trade agreement will remove 99% of
our tariffs opening up fantastic
possibilities for our companies and our
farmers to export more to Vietnam
exporting will be easier Vietnam is
bringing their standards in line with
ours which are international standards
and traditional European products will
be protected from imitation 169 food and
drink specialities geographical
indication such as Roquefort
Rioja wine prosciutto de Parma etc are
protected investment will become easier
and safer access to public procurement
services etc the trade agreement
includes strong rules of state-owned
enterprises and state subsidies will
which will help create a better level
playing field so there will be a better
legal certainty and adequate level of
protection for our investors Vietnam
also goes as all our trade agreements
nowadays beyond commercial
considerations containing ambitious
provisions or sustainable development a
firm commitment on both sides to
implement the conventions of the ILO the
International Labor Organization and I'm
also proud that we have commitments on
the Paris climate agreement in here as
regard human rights the trade agreements
is part of the EU Vietnam partnership
cooperation agree
and makes the improvement of human
rights a central part of our engagement
and dialogue with Vietnam the trade
agreements contains a broad set of
commitments and sets up a regular
dialogue a serious violation of human
rights could lead to suspension of the
whole agreement so I'm hopeful that this
can enter into force as soon of course
we have received green light from the
member states we are submitting our
proposal today to the council and then
of course the European Parliament has to
vote also later this week the we will
sign the agreement the two agreements
with EU Singapore very happy that the
council agreed to this earlier this week
Singapore is our largest trading partner
in the South East Asia hub and a
business stepping stone to the entire
Asia Pacific region this deal is
removing basically all remaining tariffs
simplifying customs procedures setting
high standards and rules opening up
markets for services like communication
environmental services and engineering
and here as well we have an ambitious
trade and sustainable development
chapter these two agreements are
testament to our commitment to open
rule-based trade and value driven trade
as you know open trade is under serious
threat today openness rule of low
multilateralism in the trade area is put
into question so and that is of course
not bad good for our economy neither for
the world so with these agreements we
setting a framework for trade in which
everybody plays according to the rules
and where social environmental matters
are also as much as a concern as
commercial ones so these few weeks have
been productive when it comes to EU
trade and investment we are also seeing
the final stage of the Japan agreement
being discussed in the European
Parliament and hopefully voted by the
end of the year thank you very much for
that Jim